dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui on va
essayer de calculer ensemble un
phénomène très intéressant qui s'appelle
l'aberration de la lumière alors
l'aberration de la lumière c'est un
phénomène que j'ai présenté dans ma
dernière vidéo de vulgarisation sur la
chaîne scienceclic et il s'agit d'un
phénomène d'optique d'un effet d'optique
qui se produit lorsqu'on se déplace à
grande vitesse dans une certaine
direction imaginons un observateur qui
se déplace à une certaine vitesse V dans
une certaine direction
cette observateur va voir des objets par
exemple des étoiles dans le ciel et il
s'avère que lorsque cette observateur se
déplace et bien ce qu'il voit devant lui
semble être contracté devant lui c'est à
dire que l'angle auquel il voit une
étoile par exemple et bien est plus
resserré que l'angle auquel se trouve
réellement l'étoile
de la même façon derrière lui
l'observateur va voir les choses se
dilater il voit la position d'un objet
qui se situerait ici par exemple dans
une direction qui est plus resserrée
vers l'avant par exemple ici donc la
position apparente des objets se décale
vers l'avant vers l'axe dans lequel se
déplace l'observateur et dans la vidéo
de vulgarisation sur ma chaîne
scienceclic j'explique que ce phénomène
est analogue à ce qu'on voit lorsqu'on
se déplace en voiture par exemple et que
la pluie qui tombe du haut vers le bas
verticalement nous semble provenir de
l'avant puisque la voiture se déplace
alors on va essayer de comprendre tout
ça et pour faire les calculs j'ai pensé
que ce serait intéressant de commencer
par faire un calcul en mécanique
classique donc sans prendre en compte
les aspects de la relativité restreinte
c'est-à-dire qu'il va s'agir d'une
approximation qui n'est valable que
lorsque la vitesse de l'observateur est
très faible par rapport à celle de la
lumière et puis dans un second temps on
va intégrer la relativité restreinte et
on va voir que ça permet de traiter le
sujet de façon rigoureuse et donc on
aura cette fois-ci une expression qui
n'est plus une approximation qui est
mais qui est valable à toutes les
vitesses bon alors commençons la
première chose qu'il faut faire c'est
d'écrire la situation de façon
mathématique donc on va imaginer un
observateur qui se situe à l'origine
d'un repère
un repère dont les axes seront X
et y
l'observateur se trouve à l'origine
uniquement à T = 0 à l'instant T = 0 et
cette observateur se déplace avec une
vitesse V dirigée suivant l'axe X dans
cette univers à deux dimensions se
trouve également une source de lumière
située à une certaine distance et dans
une certaine direction notre à la
distance D et la direction par l'angle
alpha que forme cette source par rapport
à l'axe X cette source de lumière elle
va émettre une onde lumineuse qui se
propage dans cette direction et qui
atteint l'observateur à l'instant T = 0
lorsqu'il se situe à la position x = 0
et y = 0 donc à l'origine du repère donc
si l'on remonte un peu le temps le rayon
se situait un peu avant et l'observateur
lui se situait un peu avant le long de
sa trajectoire donc ici par exemple
bon et bien commençons par décrire la
trajectoire du rayon lumineux et de
l'observateur alors la trajectoire du de
l'observateur l'air assez simple on va
l'écrire comme un vecteur x y
et les deux coordonnées X Y dépendent du
temps
ici l'observateur ne se déplace pas
selon y donc ça coordonnée Y vaut
toujours 0 par contre sa coordonnée x
évolue à la vitesse V par rapport au
temps t et donc sa coordonnait x vaut V
fois t la distance parcourue c'est la
vitesse fois le temps écoulé et on
pourrait rajouter une constante qui
correspond à la position de
l'observateur à l'instant T = 0 mais ici
à l'instant T = 0 sa position est en x =
0 donc ici on a bien trouvé l'expression
de la position de cet observateur à
chaque instant T
ça c'est pour l'observateur
maintenant qu'en est-il du rayon
lumineux
et bien pour le rayon lumineux c'est un
petit peu plus complexe mais c'est la
même idée le rayon lumineux à l'instant
T = 0 se situe ici au même endroit que
l'observateur donc ses coordonnées X de
Tyt
valent 0 en T = 0 donc elle va être
proportionnelle au temps et puis alors
quel est le vecteur vitesse du rayon et
bien le rayon se déplace dans cette
direction là donc son vecteur vitesse
déjà il a la norme petit C qui est la
vitesse de la lumière et il va avoir une
certaine direction qui est donnée par
moins cosinus de Alpha - sinus de Alpha
alors ça c'est de la trigonométrie pour
le voir on projette la position de la
source sur les axes X et Y cette
longueur ici c'est des sinus de Alpha
l'hypoténuse fois le sinus de l'angle
ici c'est d fois le cosinus de Alpha
et donc la direction ici elle est
opposée selon X et selon y assez à ces
deux axes ici donc on a des signes moins
et puis COS alpha sinalfa et le d ici ne
correspond pas à la vitesse mais
simplement la distance si la source
situait à une distance différente le
vecteur direction ne changerait pas et
donc ici on prend un vecteur direction
de normes une pour pouvoir le multiplier
par la vitesse de la lumière pour que le
vecteur vitesse tout entier est la norme
de la vitesse de la lumière
donc au cours du temps la position du
rayon lumineux c'est son vecteur vitesse
fois le temps donc c'est moins COS alpha
x T et - C'est sin alpha X
voilà donc là on a décrit la position de
l'observateur et celle du rayon lumineux
au cours du temps et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que pour l'instant on
n'a pas choisi soit la mécanique
classique soit la relativité restreinte
on a simplement fait de la cinématique
on a décrit la position des objets dans
un repère et donc pour l'instant tout
ceci vaut aussi bien en mécanique
classique quand mécanique relativiste
mais ce qui va changer de la physique
classique à la physique relativiste
c'est la façon dont on passe de se
référentiel là dans lequel la source est
immobile et l'observateur est en
mouvement au référentiel de
l'observateur qui observe dans lequel
l'observateur est immobile et c'est
vraiment ce changement de référentiel
qu'il a va être différent entre la
physique classique qui utilise la
relativité de Galilée et la physique
relativiste qui utilise la relativité
d'Einstein la relativité restreinte
alors commençons par faire le calcul en
mécanique classique
en physique classique ce que nous dit
Galilée c'est simplement que pour passer
dans le référentiel de l'observateur on
peut tout décaler décaler tout l'univers
de sorte à placer l'observateur au
centre de notre repère
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est simplement
soustraire la position de l'observateur
ici ce vecteur là à la position du rayon
lumineux alors c'est parti je vais
écrire qu'on est en physique classique
je vais prendre la couleur verte pour
distinguer ensuite de la de la physique
relativiste
en physique classique la position de
l'observateur et bien elle devient
00 puisqu'on soustrait la position de
l'observateur à elle-même et la position
du rayon lumineux et bien cette fois-ci
c'est ceci - VT donc c'est moins c'est
que Alpha t - VT
et ceci ne change pas donc c'est moins
c'est si alpha t
et ici on a la position du rayon
lumineux par rapport à l'observateur à
chaque instant et ce qui est très
intéressant ici c'est que le vecteur
vitesse donc si on factorise par t on
obtient moins c'est que Alpha plus V et
- cynalfa
fois le temps ce vecteur ici c'est la
vitesse c'est la vitesse et la direction
du rayon lumineux dans le référentiel de
l'observateur et on voit que sa norme
elle n'est plus égale à la vitesse de la
lumière elle n'est plus égale à petit C
puisqu'ici on a ajouté ce plus V et en
fait c'est assez logique puisque la
lumière n'a aucune raison d'avoir une
vitesse invariante en physique classique
si vous regardez un train et que dans ce
train quelqu'un lance une balle et bien
vu depuis le quai la balle semble aller
plus vite que vu depuis le train et de
la même façon la lumière n'a aucun rôle
particulier en physique classique et
donc sa vitesse semble changer d'un
référentiel à l'autre
donc c'est pour cette raison que le
calcul qu'on fait ici est une
approximation en physique classique et
cette approximation ne va fonctionner
que si ce petit V ici est très faible
par rapport à ces c'est-à-dire
uniquement si l'observateur se déplace
très lentement par rapport à la vitesse
de la lumière ce qui bien sûr englobe
quand même des vitesses très élevées par
rapport à notre quotidien bon et bien
maintenant on a presque terminé il
suffit de déterminer la direction dans
laquelle l'observateur voit cette source
lumineuse c'est à dire la direction de
ce vecteur vitesse alors pour faire ça
et bien on va factoriser par la norme du
vecteur donc on va la calculer
explicitement donc c'est la racine
carrée de ceci au carré et je vais tout
de suite utiliser l'identité remarquable
que A+B au carré c'est a² + 2Ab + b².
donc ceci au carré c'est
carré
+ 2 AB
+ B carré
+ ceci en bas
au carré
ça c'est la norme de mon vecteur vitesse
maintenant c'est carré ici on voit qu'il
est multiplié par cos² Alpha + sin²
alpha ce qui vaut 1
donc la norme du vecteur vitesse ici
on peut la factoriser donc si je
l'appelle grand N
c'est c²+v² + 2CV causalfa et donc ce
vecteur ici est égal à moins grand N t
fois un vecteur ici qui cette fois-ci
est un vecteur unité donc qui indique
uniquement la direction dans laquelle
l'observateur voit la source qui vaut
c'est que Alpha + V sur ce grand N donc
c'est à dire sur Racine de
ces carrés plus V carré + 2 CV cause
alpha
et en bas c'est si alpha
sur Racine de
c²+v² + 2 CV causes alpha
voilà donc cette expression assez
complexe mais ce qu'il faut se dire
c'est que ce vecteur maintenant est un
vecteur unité c'est à dire que si la
source est vue par l'observateur
à cet endroit là dans un une direction
différente caractérisée par l'angle
alpha tild et bien ce vecteur c'est
vraiment le vecteur unité dirigé dans
cette direction c'est à dire c'est le
vecteur COS alpha tild sin alpha tid
donc ceci on peut dire que c'est égal au
cosinus alors uniquement ce vecteur là
si on oublie tout ça uniquement ce
vecteur là c'est égal au cosinus de
alphathed l'angle apparent dans lequel
l'observateur voit la source et sinus al
fatigue
voilà et donc ici on peut écrire une
égalité donc prenons par exemple la
première égalité ici on peut écrire
quand physique classique l'aberration de
la lumière est donnée par cosinus de
Alpha tild est égal à et je vais ici
diviser tout par petit C en haut et en
bas donc ici le C42
le V carré devient V carré sur C carré
et ici le 2 CV devient de V sur C
pourquoi je fais ça c'est tout
simplement pour exprimer cette grandeur
en fonction du rapport V sur C puisque
c'est ce rapport là qui va distinguer la
physique classique dans laquelle ce
rapport est presque nul de la physique
relativiste dans laquelle ce rapport
devient plus élevé et proche de 1 donc
COS alpha tild est égal à cause alpha
là c'est si on avait aucune aberration
on aurait que ça le fatigue des quelques
alphas les deux angles seraient les
mêmes plus V sur C
sur racine carrée de 1 + alors devez sur
C comme alpha
plus V carré sur ces carrés
cette expression c'est l'expression de
l'aberration en physique classique et
vous aurez noté qu'on n'a jamais supposé
que notre objet est un rayon lumineux ça
pourrait être n'importe quel objet une
balle une onde sonore en physique
classique n'importe quel objet qui est
vu en se déplaçant à la vitesse V va
être vu avec une direction apparente
différente qui est cette direction là
donc si on voulait calculer alpha t-il
il faudrait prendre le arc cosinus qui
est la fonction réciproque du cosinus de
tout ça
en particulier cette expression elle
vaut tout à fait dans le cas de la pluie
qui tombe sur la voiture est-ce qu'on
peut voir en se convaincant de façon
mathématique c'est que cette chose à
droite elle est plus grande que COS
alpha donc le cosinus d'Alpha tild est
plus grand que le cosinus d'Alpha donc
l'angle apparent et plus rapproché de
l'axe X que l'angle réel
une petite précision pour terminer c'est
que ici le rapport V sur C doit être
très faible si on veut utiliser cette
formule dans le cas d'un rayon lumineux
par contre le rapport V sur C peut
valoir n'importe quoi si on étudie un
objet qui lui-même a une vitesse de
déplacement c'est inférieur très
inférieur à la vitesse de la lumière
donc par exemple si on étudie une goutte
de pluie qui tombe à une certaine
vitesse qui est bien sûr très faible par
rapport à celle de la lumière et bien la
vitesse c ici serait la vitesse de la
goutte de pluie la vitesse V sur la
vitesse de la voiture et cette formule
serait quasiment exacte prise tel quel
puisque la situation peut tout à fait
être décrite par la physique classique
mais maintenant on va passer au calcul
en relativité restreinte oublions tout
ça reprenons nos deux expressions qui
donnent la position de l'observateur et
du rayon lumineux au cours du temps
et on va passer en relativité restreinte
et je vais prendre une couleur
différente du bleu par exemple pour
faire le calcul cette fois-ci en
relativité
alors ce que nous dit la relativité
restreinte c'est que la position de
l'observateur va à nouveau être
00 mais par contre la position du rayon
lumineux va être différente et en
particulier parce que le temps de
l'observateur qu'on pourrait appeler
tiptide n'est pas le même que le temps
de se référentiel-ci qu'on appelle t
alors le calcul est un peu plus
fastidieux et pour faire ça on va avoir
besoin de décrire la position de notre
Observateur et de notre rayon lumineux
non plus dans l'espace mais dans
l'espace-temps donc il va falloir
ajouter une coordonnée à nos vecteurs si
on augmente la taille de nos vecteurs il
faut rajouter une première coordonnée de
temps
qui vaut tout simplement t
donc cette fois-ci on a plus la position
de l'observateur et du rayon dans
l'espace mais dans l'espace-temps en
incluant leur coordonnées de temps et
d'espace
et à partir de là on va pouvoir faire le
changement de repère puisque en
relativité restreinte en fait le temps
et l'espace sont des directions dans
lesquelles on peut tourner on peut
passer d'une coordonnée spatiale à une
coordonnée temporelle et vice versa un
peu comme dans l'espace si vous tournez
vous pouvez passer d'une coordonnée x à
une coordonnée Y donc c'est un peu la
même chose dans l'espace-temps on peut
passer d'une coordonnée x à une
coordonnée T et vice versa donc
lorsqu'on fait un changement de
référentiel en relativité il est
essentiel de prendre en compte la
coordonnée du temps puisque le
changement de référentiel en fait
correspond à une rotation dans
l'espace-temps
alors pour faire ce changement de
référentiel on va appliquer ce qu'on
appelle une transformation de Lorentz on
en a déjà parlé dans une vidéo
précédente on a démontré l'expression
des transformations de Lawrence la
transformation de Lawrence qui nous
intéresse c'est celle qui permet de
booster le référentiel c'est à dire de
changer de référentiel d'une vitesse V
puisqu'on veut se placer dans le
référentiel de l'observateur et elle
s'écrit de la façon suivante
tétilde la coordonnée tente dans le
référentiel de l'observateur x style la
coordonnée x dans le référentiel de
l'observateur et ytild
vos gamma fois t - V sur C au carré x
alors gamma c'est le fameux facteur de
Lorenz qui est défini comme étant un sur
racine carrée de 1 - v carré sur ces
carrés x style cette fois-ci c'est égal
à gamma fois x - v x T et voyez ici
qu'on a bien pris x auquel on a retiré
VT donc comme lorsqu'on changeait de
référentiel avec la relativité
galiléenne mais cette fois-ci avec ce
facteur gamma ici qui vient s'ajouter
qui est vraiment un facteur relativiste
en particulier vous voyez bien que la
position de l'observateur puisqu'elle
est égale à VT selon X et bien sûr fait
VT - VT ça donne 0 donc dans le nouveau
référentiel x styled pour l'observateur
vaut toujours 0 il est bien au centre de
son propre repère
et enfin ytilde puisqu'ici le mouvement
est uniquement selon X et bien YT ne
change pas par rapport à l'ancienne
coordonnée ytil vaut y ça c'est la
transformation de Lorentz qui permet de
changer de référentiel
et bien maintenant qu'on a cette
expression c'est génial on va pouvoir
l'appliquer à notre rayon lumineux pour
obtenir la nouvelle position du rayon
lumineux donc la position telle qu'elle
est vue dans le référentiel de
l'observateur et déterminer l'angle
alpha tild
alors c'est parti pour le rayon lumineux
on va avoir tétine qui vaut gamma fois t
alors t ici c'est bien t
- V sur c² X X ici x c'est tout ça c'est
moins COS alpha t donc on a un mois donc
le moins se transforme en plus on a un C
donc le C4 se transforme en C
et on a COS alpha t
ici on voit qu'on peut factoriser par T
donc je vais sortir le petit t
et on obtient cette expression ça c'est
la coordonnée temporelle de la position
du rayon lumineux dans le nouveau
référentiel
alors maintenant on peut faire la même
chose avec X styled xtlid c'est égal à
gamma fois X X c'est tout ça donc c'est
moins COS alpha et encore une fois je
vais factoriser par T
- VT donc - V et le T factorisé devant
et enfin ytil = y valait ça donc ytil
vaut moins c'est sin alpha
encore une fois je vais factoriser par T
voilà donc à partir de là on a obtenu la
position du rayon lumineux au cours du
temps alors il faut faire attention ici
ça c'est le temps dans l'ancien repère
ça c'est le nouveau temps mais on a
obtenu la position dans le nouveau
référentiel alors on n'a pas encore
obtenu l'angle alpha fatigue mais on a
presque fini puisqu'ici si on prend
uniquement les coordonnées spatiales on
peut obtenir la direction ou plutôt le
vecteur vitesse tel qu'il est vu dans le
référentiel de l'observateur alors ici
encore une fois c'est pas vraiment le
vecteur vitesse puisque on va utiliser
la coordonnée T pour décrire ce
mouvement alors que T n'est pas la
coordonnée du temps dans le nouveau
référentiel c'est la coordonnée du temps
dans l'ancien référentiel il faut faire
un peu attention mais bon si on
s'intéresse uniquement à ce vecteur
direction ici on a un vecteur qui vaut
moins
gamma secos alpha plus V
et cylindre
alors le moins ici c'est le même mois
qu'on avait ici
ça vient du fait que le rayon lumineux
ne part pas dans cette direction il
arrive dans cette direction et donc si
on s'intéresse à la direction dans
laquelle il est vu on peut tout à fait
remplacer le moins par un plus et ça
nous permettra d'avoir le cosinus
d'Alpha tild sans avoir à changer de
signe
très bien sauf que ce vecteur vitesse
pour l'instant il a une norme il n'est
pas ce n'est pas un vecteur unitaire et
donc on ne sait pas quel est le cosinus
puisque ce vecteur est censé être égal à
une norme N qu'on ne connaît pas fois le
cosinus de alphatide et le sinus de
l'alphabet
alors il va falloir déterminer cette
norme alors là on peut déterminer la
norme avec le théorème de Pythagore la
norme N c'est la racine carrée de la
somme des carrés de ces deux choses là
Yama au carré donc ça c'est 1 sur 1 - v
carré sur C carré
x tout ça au carré je vais l'expandre
tout de suite donc on a C carré cos²
alpha + V carré plus 2 VC COS alpha il
me manque un C
plus ceci au carré donc plus
c'est carré SIM carré alpha
là on voit qu'on a une expression qui
commence à devenir assez complexe c'est
normal on est en relativité mais on va
pouvoir la réduire un peu alors tout
d'abord on va passer tout sur un même
dénominateur en multipliant ce dernier
terme par un moins V carré sur C carré
ça va nous permettre d'avoir un gamma en
facteur qui est ce terme là
fois la racine carrée de tout ça c'est
carré cos² alpha + V carré + 2 wc cause
alpha
plus ce six fois ceci donc plus c'est
carré signe carré alpha moins V carré s√
voilà maintenant vous pouvez remarquer
certaines choses ici on a C carré fois
cos² alpha + sin² alpha donc comme tout
à l'heure comment en physique classique
ceci devient un
et on a ce nouveau terme ici qui n'était
pas présent en physique classique que
l'on peut combiner avec ce V carré ici
vous voyez qu'on a v carré facteur de 1
- 6² alpha et 1 - 6² alpha c'est COS
carré alpha donc ici c'est comme si on
avait plus V carré
cos²
et là en fait c'est assez génial puisque
vous savez peut-être remarqué une
identité remarquable c'est le fait que
ici on a gamma racine carrée de c+v²
parce que ceci c'est A + B au carré vous
avez bien a²
et deux AB
alors ici alpha peut être négatif mais
il ne peut pas être plus petit que -1
donc tout ceci ne peut pas être plus
petit que c'est moins V et puisque V ne
peut pas être plus grand que la vitesse
de la lumière tout ceci est positif donc
on peut enlever la racine carrée et dire
que N la norme de ce vecteur c'est
simplement gamma fois c+v que on a bien
simplifié quand même notre expression de
départ
et bien voilà là on a terminé puisque il
suffit de diviser ce vecteur par la
norme pour obtenir le cosinus de Alpha
donc on va prendre cette première
composante
gamma x COS alpha plus V et on va la
diviser par la norme N qui vaut gamma
c+v que Alpha
les gamins se simplifient et ici pour
finir on peut diviser par C comme je
l'avais fait tout à l'heure
pour obtenir quelque chose qui dépend du
rapport V sur C et cette expression
c'est ce qui donne le cosinus de Alpha
tild la direction perçue par
l'observateur
en relativité restreinte et donc cette
fois-ci on a plus d'approximations et si
vous comparez avec l'ancienne expression
en physique classique
voilà et bien vous voyez qu'en réalité
l'expression en physique relativiste en
relativité elle est presque plus simple
j'ai envie de dire elle est plus simple
puisqu'on avait ce terme gamma ici qui
nous a entraîné un moins V carré fois 6
carré alpha et qui donc a transformé ce
terme-ci en V carré sur ces carrés cos²
alpha c'est bien qu'on appuie identifier
une identité remarquable et supprimer la
racine carrée en bas donc pour conclure
l'expression relativiste elle est
presque identique à l'expression en
physique classique vous voyez qu'on a
bien COS alpha plus V sur C
et en bas on a bien un terme qui est
presque le même à une différence qui
serait ici de soustraire V carré sur ces
carrés
signe carré alpha et puisque V carré sur
ces carrés dans l'approximation de la
physique classique c'est un rapport qui
est très très faible et bien cette
différence en fait ne fait presque aucun
effet en physique classique donc les
deux expressions sont bien compatibles
lorsque la vitesse de l'observateur est
très faible mais par contre cette
expression là n'est valable que pour un
rayon lumineux donc ici le petit C ne
peut s'appliquer que lorsqu'il est égal
à la vitesse de la lumière quand on
quand on étudie un objet qui se déplace
à la vitesse de la lumière et donc cette
expression ne marche pas si on étudie
par exemple une goutte de pluie qui
tombe puisqu'on a utilisé le fait que ce
petit C c'est le même C qui intervient
dans les transformations de Lorent c'est
à dire que c'est la constante de
l'espace-temps qui gère en fait toute la
relativité restreinte
alors pour finir on va faire une petite
application dans la limite lorsque C et
V tente vers la même valeur c'est-à-dire
lorsque l'observateur s'approche de la
vitesse de la lumière et bien vous voyez
que ici on a à peu près 1 ici on a à peu
près 1 aussi donc on aurait un plus que
ça
sur un plus que Alpha ce qui va à peu
près 1 donc le cosinus de Alpha tild
serait à peu près égal à 1 et ceci
implique que Alpha tild soit à peu près
égale à zéro c'est à dire que tout ce
que l'on voit dans notre champ de vision
serait concentré devant nous